has a non-married woman there's people
saying I'm being vague
I would wake up make sure everyone's
alive and well I'd start going about my
day think about what I'm gonna do if I
have children I'm getting them ready if
my husband's going to work and I'm still
looking after the kids at home you can
go off to work you okay have you eaten
cool let me know about your day be on
about your way I'll take care of the
kids if we've got any stuff coming up
try to take them for a walk hopefully
the dishwasher's done by the night
before empty it out go about my bus
think about what I'm gonna cook look in
the fridge start preparing that one's
watching TV ones and then it will walk
on